um
we'll get on straight away
apologies for absence thank you jesse
thank you chair apologies from
councillor wrench
minutes
minutes of the last meeting page three
to seven
and i will
read the page numbers out
base three
place four
h5
page six
phase seven
anybody got any comments coming uh get
over repository secondary then please
propose simon newton secondary
yeah okay
never mind um
right sure click
again
abstentions
free
okay
all right
come to the action list
aj
minute number 165
issues
okay we'll leave that alone until we get
our response
sorry yes
i was what we should have responded by
now so it's quite a simple question is
it snagging or isn't it
i i i must agree i do agree with that
but why can't we get sean to have a give
us a response
sure he's off today so we'll get a
response from him and circulate it okay
okay
for that one and the
economic strategy
this has been completed by chris fuller
email sent
so we can we can remove that now
enforcement caseload issues lack of
enforcement
officer prioritization okay that's
obviously the email that has been sent
there
so that's completed
167
we could take we can take that one off
once
about enforcement
maintenance of plants and flowers
included
in the new
gm services
obviously
everybody had an email from richard yeah
yeah
and that's completed okay that's right
move on
peter
sorry on the
report about
round nation
richard has taken into account future
climate patterns when considering what
to plan
from the agenda always
declarations of interest you all
understand about declarations of
agent matters
forward the permission of the chair
we'll add button on obviously okay okay
uh agreement um
gender parts one and two we've got no
part two
right item eight homelessness strategy
uh oh
oh is it
it's china
yeah janet can i get this right
thank you
for being late
i'm not the right time
um as members will have
seen there isn't actually a report
provided with this item
um
that doesn't
say that we're not hugely active um in
this area the issue is that actually
there's so much going on at the present
time that we've not actually managed to
encapsulate that into a working strategy
as yet
members will be aware of various things
that are that are happening for example
the uh the recent efforts around trying
to acquire sully house for temporary
accommodation
and which unfortunately wasn't
successful but there was a subsequent
um agreement that we can take the
funding for for that to invest um in
another property as and when that became
available
and in that same report and it was also
given the
information was provided to members
around
a recent funding bid that was successful
and to the devon county council from
their comp fund
and which will allow us to purchase
free
and temporary
homeless units and
that while that was successful the
difficulty is going to be finding
somewhere for them to to go
now members um there's an upcoming uh
workshop for for members looking at and
the recent outcome of our um
uh
review of our asset plan
and we're hopeful that from that um site
a site some sites will be identified
that we can pursue both for uh these
these units that have been funded but
also um
future units uh or or maybe more
permanent um uh temporary accommodation
and not the the modular type that we're
looking at at the moment so things are
very much in the uh up in the air um at
the at the present time
once
we have uh an idea of where
these units can be can be cited um we'll
be able to to incorporate that into into
our strategy obviously this will be a
significant part of our our strategy
going forward
and so as i say i do apologize that we
don't have um such a strategy at the at
the current time but um hopefully very
shortly things will be a little bit
clearer as to as to the the way forward
for the for the authority
um
i have previously reported to to this um
group around the the pressures on our
our housing options team and they are
still in place we still have those same
issues last week we had almost 60 people
in temporary accommodation we're still
facing the same pressures
um and hopefully um in terms of a
long-term um solution or mitigation to
some of these issues and we'll be able
to identify sites and and increase our
temporary homeless accommodation
provision
but i'm happy to take any questions in
the in the meantime
have we got any idea where we want to
put these
little units they're like must be like
pods are they the the other the what
we're looking at stuff like um the kind
of containers that that sort of size but
they're single
uh or double units and with all the
facilities in um there have been there
are a couple of sites that are on the
the asset plan that may be suitable but
that's something for the uh discussion
by uh members of that meeting in a
couple of weeks time
but the
people who didn't
needed to to get to them quite easily
won't they for people who have actually
yeah access is it is important which
will reduce the viability of some of the
sites on the asset asset list yes yeah
okay anybody sorry
shelly you want to go first how many how
um so you've got the funding for these
modulators three three modular units yes
so how
many people would they house um
if we went for double units that could
be six
right okay
okay
um
right okay and after and you say like
last week
last week
yes 16. yeah are you able to say
approximately
you know how many of those were families
or
um i i don't have that information with
me i'm afraid i can i can provide that
full breakdown of the um uh the makeup
of the um
the the people who've got temporary
accommodation at the moment i can do
that and can you
can you see sorry chair all right kevin
can you
see
is it getting worse
it's not getting any better
and the the
level of demand
remains the the pressures that we have
at the moment is availability of options
for um housing those individuals in that
the the normal routes um
travel lodges holiday accommodation that
sort of thing and they are being used
this whole holiday season and the the
proprietors would prefer to use those
premises for um
for holiday use rather than working with
us we always knew that summer would be a
pressure time for us and and that is the
case but presumably this is my last one
sorry but presumably it still remains
the case which is what you said before
that
even if we get these modular units
the issue then becomes where those
people go next because once there are
people in those modular units they're
not available for
new homeless people so
yeah the issue remains that there
becomes a log jam
fundamentally there is a lack of um
suitable and affordable housing in the
district which is a which is a wider
issue which members are
well aware of and the the pressures in
terms of affordable housing all of that
sort of stuff yes that that is a that is
a difficulty
okay thank you thank you okay peter
thanks
yeah thank you
you've got huge
jana's got a huge sort of challenge i
can tell
problem the housing market and
affordability etc
i mean it's good you've got these units
lined up but three isn't really going to
make much for denting things and
also that's the problem of where to put
them i sort of sense that there's
a challenge of social stigma attached to
these units that know where you put them
even in the neighborhood
and then
make some sort of fascinating height in
terms of the gypsy encounters you know
um i mean specifically what about
bringing on back end just has that being
concerned
is that possibly a challenge in terms of
local residents or thinking that they
shouldn't be there i think councillor
you're right wherever they go um it's
it's going to be challenging and i think
members will have some difficult and
decisions to make balancing the
the issues that are facing them but also
the pressure that they'll have from
their their constituents as well
um
i i'm not
at the moment i'm not sure what sites
being put forward to members um in terms
of uh potential viability for these
modular uh units but it's it's in a
couple of weeks time so uh but from from
our point of view
uh the closer well the the biddeford
site would be beneficial in terms of my
staff being able to
um
monitor um the the locations but um you
know we'll take anything at the moment
just a sort of wider question on this
have you um
have you sort of discussed the issue of
actually purchase of mobile homes for a
more
[Music]
slightly more permanent sort of solution
stretching back to my service stage i
remember in the late 70s we had a
shortage of service accommodation and a
lot of our young families we put into or
were put into
mobile homes what we would call nowadays
mobile home it was in fact modular
very very similar
mobile home
accommodation and we're very happy there
and they were there on a long term basis
it wasn't being used as a temporary
thing but the cost i know we're into
falling into a different area here
because
we're talking about housing provision
potentially um i know they overlapped
into that but
have you have you
looked at a mobile home area or
on existing holiday sites or
actually purchasing our own and
potentially purchasing our own um
not
not as such i mean we'd still have the
issue of in terms of land and viability
and but that's certainly something we
can we can put into the mix
it's probably
one of the
quicker fixes
in that one can source mobile homes very
very quickly um you know
even second hand oh it's quite a
secondhand
secondly in terms of affordability it
would be a fraction of going down the
build route
and
being a
mid-term solution
you're
providing units that might have a life
of
10 or 15 years in them at least um
absolutely no thank you councilman we'll
certainly look into that i think i think
the the land or the location is is going
to be the the main issue with that but
um yeah what whatever whatever helps
really
anyone
cheryl cheryl sorry um where are we in
the process of providing our own social
housing
um
could i
refer to stacy for that i think that's
something that
might actually be a question better
asked answered by
that's part of the overall project so
it's similar to what janet's just said
about finding sites
once we've got some sites then we can go
into the detail of whether um and what
the feasibility are on the on the sites
that um members kind of identified
so we're we're on the project we're
still progressing and the next step is
the 17th of may workshop where we sit
down where we've got some land options
that we'll present
to members and
have that discussion
yeah john
it doesn't have to be in vidified does
it no no i mean a bit of this
around yeah old worthy yeah i mean
biddeford is there is a lot of demand in
in biddeford and there's there's
certainly advantages and for for being
based here but uh yeah i mean our our
huntsman's presentations could could
happen anywhere and obviously we've got
the yeah we've got from the house in um
in torrington
um so we're there regularly for for that
um
we don't have any provisioning in holes
where they could certainly be interested
in that yeah
right
so the
limitation on the
modular units you've got three but it's
presumed it's a cost limitation
and we've got the funding for free so
that that's the that's the starting
point we've not used modular
accommodation yet and this would be a
good way of seeing how it works in
practice and but if that if if it works
if it's viable you know we find a
suitable site and and it meets our needs
then there's no reason why we can't seek
um
bids in the future either externally or
or internally
yeah
julie sorry sorry
sorry um
two other things has anything
happened
after lastville council and it came
about the empty homes
and that the
notice of motion
um didn't
we didn't act on it
um
does anyone know i mean do you know have
you met with ruth yet or
um
not since we have their last meeting no
i know that sounds good strange but now
there's something um
because steve was off and then
um but that is still that is still
moving on if that is still going to
happen
well as john said obviously
we're hoping on the 17th that um
before tom left on phillips he
identifies the sites sean harrington has
done an assessment with some of the
sites and hopefully we will come up with
something
in and meet and have that wider
discussion about what the council is
doing in the wider
arena of hunting i think what was
suggesting was
directing our resources
developing housing because you'll have a
much bigger impact than trying to
bring the odds one or two empty
properties back in so it's about
directing the resources where they
achieve the biggest impact yeah right
okay
okay the other thing was are you are you
aware i hope i'm not speaking out of
turn here but um from councillor
christie's from the bridge trust about a
possible
are you aware of that yes and um this
could be inspection carried out on on
those premises just to satisfy ability
and then we'll we'll take this
we'll move
forward a decision from them okay thank
you thank you
okay any more questions
okay thanks dinner
very good presentation again
item nine
all right
okay um so just to give them members uh
an update on the um housing benefit reps
and ben's department
um it is fair to say that we have
got an increased um backlog um the
figures have increased from 50 47.62
sorry to 47.62 days
processing days from
25.24
days
um
from our perspective not fantastic but
um
there is a very good explanation for
why um
as members would have been aware um
during the pandemic
various government initiatives and came
out
not least the business grant so we paid
out
is it 54 million
67 million in in business grants alone
and those were all processed by by that
team and i think members were aware at
the time um and from the press that we
were told effectively to drop everything
and get those grants processed asap and
and that's what they did and they did
really well in processing them and i
think from torridge's perspective we
were um
one of the top in the country to get
them administered to our business
to the businesses
um we then had the track and trace
scheme
um
again really important to enable those
that had to isolate um due to covert to
be uh to receive that one-off payment
now i think first of all when that
scheme
was first rolled out we were one of the
lowest covered rates in the country so
the amount of claims that we were
processing were quite few and then as
you'll all be aware
um
we then became one of the highest
covered rates in the country so
that again was processed by that team
and effectively that was all still while
the business grants were being paid out
so the business grants have consistently
been paid out to businesses through
various schemes and throughout the whole
period
um
and now obviously as as as you'll be
aware we've got the energy rebate scheme
and again
that runs through through those teams
through that that department
um so three
big initiatives all having to go through
the reds and bend system
um and again with the energy rebate
scheme that they're working on that now
we've got to make those payments
starting from now going up until
september
um
but as well as the
mandatory scheme for those in a to d
we've then got the discretionary scheme
and and that's an application process
the team have to make those assessments
as with the business grants you know it
we have to put the processes in place
but that's not been helped by the fact
that a lot of these initiatives as you
all know they've been announced in the
press
um before we've been told and then we
have to put the resources in place the
schemes in place the checking in place
um to announce you know to allow those
to be
to be processed
and then we've had the hardship grants
as well so it's been a lot um for the
team um
on top of their day-to-day work now the
obvious answer would be why don't you
just recruit staff to fill the gap
um
not easy i think first of all
um we were never sure of how long these
schemes would go on for um you know
quite often if it's a one-off scheme
you can cover that for a short period
um
but very often
more money was pushed out or new
versions of the scheme were pushed out
and
it's never quite as simple as just
bringing people in off the street to be
able to administer
the revs and benefit job alone is six
months training you have to learn the
processes you have to learn the
legislation um so it does take a long
time and
when you're training or when the staff
within the team are training
it takes
time off them doing the day job to be
able to sit back and train
now the the reason the department for
work and pensions are interested in our
figures is because we process the
housing benefit claims for them
um you would have heard jan talking a
moment ago about temporary accommodation
and the increase in the temporary
accommodation well that also affects the
revs and ben's team um because they have
to make the assessments
in relation to the temporary
accommodation
and
as it is on as it says it's temporary so
it moves around
tenants often move around a lot so each
time
um a move is implemented
a new assessment has to be made
and quite often they have to drop
everything to do those assessments
because if they don't do the assessment
quickly um it puts an extra
pressure onto the housing team because
they could lose those placements so i
think it's it's fair to say it's all
been a perfect
uh storm i'm not defending um the delays
but i hope what i'm saying kind of gives
some context as to why
and of course it's the age-old problem
um as soon as there's a delay
um
it compounds the situation because
people are ringing and chasing you know
quite understandably because they want
to know where their um system or where
their application is in in the process
um in terms of what we are doing to
resolve um
the the situation we have um employed
two agency members of staff
um who are fully trained and qualified
to start hitting the backlog
um and we've also employed um two
people in march
but again they've got no experience or
training so it's going to take a while
to get them up to speed um
and we've got adverts out for another
full-time full-time assessor
um
from our perspective the dwp is coming
in to audit us on the 9th of may
to look at how we process our claims
and again not unwelcomed but it does
cause a problem because
when they come in toward it obviously
that takes the team off the day job to
to to to be involved in the audit
so that's
in a nutshell from my perspective
obviously i'm happy to take any any
questions
anybody questions
uh great interest and you yeah thank you
very much
again enormous challenges i can see that
with all the extra work
of general local authorities by the
government um
the obvious question is have you
identified any
real hardship problems amongst claimants
of benefit as a result of this situation
not to my knowledge i mean obviously
from their perspective it's frustrating
and upsetting um what we have stopped is
any um
enforcement action in terms of council
tax arrears um
because we don't want to summons people
to court for non-payment if it is the
fact that they've paid or that their
benefits might kick in to assist with
that so we we've stopped that for the
time being until we can
clear the backlog because what we didn't
want to find is we've we've summoned
people to attend only to find that they
they're waiting for a benefit claim to
be processed um so hopefully not
um the only thing that i can say from
that perspective is if there was a
change that was an increase obviously
that increase would be backdated i'm not
saying it's perfect
but we're doing like what we can you
know i think from our perspective as
well it's not great from the team
perspective it's not great from a star
from world perspective i either so with
we're doing all we can
um and in terms of
um
trying to minimize telephone calls going
through to them we've shut the phones
down and rev some bends for half a day
because what we've also found is they've
been on the phone for six hours a day
with people chasing which is fine but
then it doesn't it doesn't
clear the backlog it doesn't help them
process the applications and we put them
last on the list from our automated
telephone system so and they don't get
any other calls that they shouldn't be
getting for other teams
energy rebate
obviously we're going to have some extra
costs you know how much it's going to
cost us no we actually didn't get
government grants
to
offset that
yeah so we will get new burdens
to cover the administration of this work
it covers the whole lot
uh regulated initial allocation and
they'll reassess over the fullness of
times
but
i would strongly suspect that we will
get more in funding than we will
directly incur
but then that doesn't take into account
officer time that is incurred
we could have done without the money and
not the burden there's a simple truth of
that
right
right
simon
stacy the
you've described um
the pressure that's on the staff
but we've had a period of time
when we've
asked the staff to in effect do two jobs
at the same time
um and we've so we've seriously
increased the burden of work on staff
and they were busy already
what is your assessment at the moment i
know this is a fairly confidential
question what is your assessment at the
moment with regard to
staff retention
i mean how pissed off are your stuff
that they're actually getting close to
very oh sorry
um
i apologize for vulgarizing no
direct
i can't say that they're
overly happy but i think
because
predominantly and because they are
getting
a lot of irate people on the phone um
consistently and i think we all have the
odd day where you have um irate
customers on the phone and it you know
it's not exactly uplifting but i think
they've got that
um consistently but i think the other
difficulty is there's a whole host of
factors um when it comes to recruitment
um and there's many things that we can't
compete against and i think you all have
seen the
the press and and
and the competition when it comes to
salaries we we can't compete in that in
that way um so i think recruitment and
again this isn't isn't as a secret
because it's come up time and time again
but recruitment
as a whole across authority is difficult
um am i concerned about the team yeah to
be honest you know
okay i am
um
in terms of staff role is it difficult
yes
um and i don't have an easy answer to
that at the moment
um it's just been i think relentless
couple of years
but not just for revs and ben's i think
but for many of the teams and i and i i
think it's it's a difficult time and we
definitely got difficult times going
forward
do i want to lose anybody else on the
team no you know
definitely but
yeah it's
i'm not sure if that answered the
question but right
just mentioned
can all of us just remember if we want
to use french we could get sweet stuff i
would say sorry yes
i don't mind the bridge but just
um anyway
and steve wanted to come in today
stacy alluded to your colleagues right
across the
public sector experiencing difficulties
in recruitment is a very challenging
market at the moment i think when you
look at when you talk about housing
markets you say so either buyers or
sellers market in employment terms at
the moment it's an employee's market and
employees are demanding
different levels of pay uh the benefits
we've got in the public sector and at
toys is you know we've got
um
different range of benefits from
pensions uh flexible work in holiday
all
[Music]
quite often better than uh some other
sectors so that kind of adds to the
package of benefits we can offer for
recruitment but you know at some point
though that things will kind of will
revert back
it is very very challenging across
the entire public sector
to recruit employees
okay
shirley
i i just want to say that
i just find it really concerning when
you obviously do as well it's really
concerning that and then
we all know there's nothing worse than
being anxious about something and trying
to find out about something and not
being able to get through and not being
able to get an answer and particularly
if it's you know people's potential
livelihoods and futures and things like
this it's just a real worry
how how do we compare do you know how we
compare as a council to other councils
our other councils because presumably
a lot of the situation is the same in
other councils as the things they've had
to
activate for the government etc i mean
are are they finding the same issues
yeah i mean i don't have the figures
available but i know sat on the meetings
they're all under the same pressures
they've all had the same same schemes to
roll out and we hear time and time again
it's the same staff having to administer
these these schemes
you know and really you're right from a
telephone point of view when people
can't get through they get frustrated
but really the message that we need to
get out is please stop ringing because
it's causing more delays into and quite
often because they're ringing or
emailing that's having because it goes
in the system and then someone's having
to recheck and recheck and it's not
getting us any further i i don't think
from our perception we want to keep
putting messages out please don't call
but it is hard because actually if they
weren't on the phone it would mean the
team could process the claims a bit
quicker um and i know it's difficult
from the team's perspective being on the
phone
and we did review that we did log it
and we we discovered that they were on
the phone more than
more than not for most of the working
day actually and presumably if people
come to us
i mean i don't know about other
counselors but if if i haven't been in
this position but if somebody came to me
and asked me to look into something then
i would be a blockage in the system as
well if i try to contact someone i mean
it just it can just accentuate the
delays can't it it's hard because then
we you know we've got the ukraine scheme
as well and um you know and then
that those payments have got to be
processed as well so you know i think
from the start perspective they
want to do the schemes because they're
good schemes but there is really no more
more resource to be able to
um
yeah it was saturated i think and i
think we can all do it for a short
period i think it's just that the length
and
rep of them and i i don't think it's
helped because the government guidance
has consistently changed throughout the
process or they're they've announced the
initiatives and the guidance isn't there
um and then people are on the telephone
obviously wanting that you know the
energy rebate scheme is a classic
example they want their payment but we
haven't necessarily got the guidance to
be able to administer
thank you
simon
without the french's time um
[Music]
dwp audit on the ninth of this month
what is what are the potential outcomes
of that audit in
how powerful is that all in if they turn
around and say actually
statutory business here you're not doing
it to standard
yeah we take we we accept all the
excuses and reasons however the reality
is output not just not to the standard
required what can they do to us
what they're coming in to look at is our
processing and to check that there's
nothing that can be changed in our
process
um so i hope
this is just uh sure so i'm hoping i
mean joe's joe wells the benefits
manager has had a very good relationship
with them i'm hoping that nothing's
going to happen but they're going to
come in and review our processes and
just see that it is sheer volume as
opposed to anything else now
they haven't discussed any further
measures after that point and i'm hoping
that there
won't be um to be honest it you know
that they
we're not the only ones in this
situation but i understand and joe
understands why they would have to come
in and review that we are doing things
correctly from a process point of view
but nothing's been so joey's going to
deal with this issue
joe's meeting with them they don't want
to see senior management
just just to add to that and they will
probably have a bit more detail than me
and so in terms of processing and
accuracy there have been
historically our audits have been um
clean and good so that's obviously
audited on an annual basis in terms of
current staff before return
and accuracy so it's it's it's volume
there to be concerned with they have now
what's called an la
error rate which is a local authority at
a rate so they obviously give some
allowance in it the expect that local
authorities will on occasion make errors
and they're less than
one percent significantly below i think
i think it's point eight point four
eight and one percent once you go beyond
that then you lose money they don't
reimburse you um
um how's the medical subsidy so that's
our incentive on accuracy is not to go
below
less than half of the percent of error
in our calculations and that they get
that information
from when grant funds can do the
external order
what i can say is they don't want to see
anyone from senior management so i'm
guessing that's a
um a good thing um and i did say to joe
i'd make myself available for the whole
day and she said nobody doesn't want to
see you so
i'm assuming that's a good indication um
one more question claire
um thank you
stacey you said
you had um
introduced a half day where you had no
phone calls
when you realized the volume of
telephone calls
now as counsellors we need to be
supportive and sending out a message
that
you know these phone calls are
a major
issue for you in delaying staff getting
on with the job
could we propose that we have a whole
day
once a week
for the interim period
and that as councillors we take it upon
ourselves to justify and explain to
people
why this is happening
be honest with our public and our
constituents who are
part of this list of
47.62 days waiting for their claim
so that everybody is aware of it
let's be honest
with
the people
because if they understand what you've
told us today
they know that there is a reason for it
and there is
movement and this is what we're doing to
try and address it
and i think that would be a really
positive thing to both your staff to
allow them to get on with it
because they can't feel very happy about
this kind of figure
um and that we are supporting them in
backing them up with
the public
um
that's one question
the second little bit sorry
i've been sitting here waiting you know
i'm not on this committee come on when
we talk about the number of people in
this backlog
how many applications are we actually
talking about
because we talk about
uh how many days backlog it is but we
don't actually talk about
the number and volume of people that it
is affecting
do you have any sense of that or isn't
it i can get those because i haven't got
them um
in front of me but it doesn't
necessarily mean people are waiting um
for the benefits it might be that
there's a change in circumstance that
they're not you know that they need to
update their benefits that they're
working that they're not working so it
could just be a um a slight tweak um so
we just don't know you just know that
it's requests on the system effectively
i mean i can find out more more detail
for you
um in terms of shutting the phone off
more i'm sure the revs and pens team
would absolutely welcome that the
problem is it doesn't always necessarily
stop the calls coming through to the
authority so they'll bring the customer
services team or another team and then
those teams will broaden the messages to
rev some veterans so
it it doesn't necessarily help
but it does give them that half a day
respite and i'm sure they would welcome
it but i'd have to talk to other teams
to see if it would
ultimately
um because we had to think about teams
all the teams so
don't we and people aren't not ringing
during that half day unfortunately um
i think i i mean i agree with claire
actually we could go for a day but we
all need to know the day so that when we
go to our parish council meetings we can
tell the paris councils who then can get
it out to
the rest of the parish that don't ring
torridge on wednesday
because there'll be no answer
because we have this big problem and i
think if we should look at the station
to be quite honest don't you agree
all right
no we don't
you want to say something
steve
sorry
do you want to come back to something
closer
yeah i think it's important that we
understand that this background is these
different categories of people and it's
not people who are
not going to have their benefit
determined and they're going to be made
homeless because their benefit hasn't
been determined so i think it's good to
hear that as to to what that figure
actually entails
so thank you for that spacing but i
still think
i think if we prime customer services
with the right message
for people coming through
and we do a publicity issue about it not
just through parish councils but
actually in the paper saying look we're
doing something positive we want to get
better we need to i think we could we
should really look at ourselves
especially well then you have to solve
you know sympathizing people phoning
just you know not getting responses it's
a sort of national disease now not being
able to get through to people having to
wait on the phone
i mean banks have been markets and ages
so the lord knows how long
to think about it
yeah
anyway yes
we can look at that then can we yeah
good
anybody else no
move on
thank you stay tuned
right five to ten
oh this is you
yeah do you want the microphone
um yeah thank you so this one
this was uh has been on the agenda for
this committee to
consider through the implementation
process of our new leisure services so
as of the the 1st of april 22
1610 obviously handed over handed back
the sites and leisure services uh to
active storage
um so
two out of the three sites are fully
operational so northern and poles worthy
and we're still experiencing some
problems at torrington uh the the boiler
has been fixed the original leak
was fixed so some excavation done around
the pool
the pool was
but there's still an amount of water
leaking from the pool so the contractors
are back
trying to resolve that matter currently
so we haven't got a specific date
because it depends exactly what the
problem is and how that can how how and
when that can be fixed
um the centers are the two centers that
are open and provide
works done on them to make them look a
little bit better painted in corporate
colors
staff a number of staff that we
recruited
and the recruitments being particularly
successful in that in that area
the centers have been busy as i
understand
there are still some teething problems
with the the back office functionality
around the website
and
booking applications but
that our leisure
services operational manager is dealing
with active nation to resolve those as
quickly and as smoothly as possible
so that's just a brief update i'd just
like to say one thing steve i've had two
people phoned me from
around oldsworth
saying uh fantastic if there's the goku
holdsworthy legend
now uh the people who we've employed
which are
i think
in australia they're the same people
are
are really enjoying it an athlete and
they smile you said well both of them
said they smile man
but yeah they they they
both say i'm good at this
it's exciting
so obviously we did the right thing
not turning it into an um
anyway
anybody's got
cheryl
yeah yeah good yeah
and i think i think eventually it will
take a hell of a lot more people that
that will go to my 16th time
you know question peter aims yeah i've
said it said it before that's sort of a
bit boring but the
north and paul um you talk about
making it sort of clear to people as a
big takeover
creating corporate colors and things the
exterior of normal pool do you know when
that may be cleaned up and painted or is
that a big possibility
i've got those details
it doesn't work absolutely
okay
any more questions
no we'll move on
right item 11
um
[Laughter]
can
it's good to see you all again it's been
a while finally john updated uh at the
last meeting because i wasn't able to
attend
so it's just to give you a brief update
after one month of the grains
maintenance um
stuff and service coming in house
um just basically where we are what
we've achieved so far
so to date um we've currently got one
working supervisor three permanent staff
that should beat across as i said before
was supposed to be four but one decided
not to
we've got one summer season starting
today
and as of next week we'll have another
full-time uh employee and the other
summer seasonal so that should be
um our compliment the season for our
first year of of testing
and hopefully
improving service obviously then we've
got mike crocker as well who's part-time
who's also covering and supporting the
property team
as well as
um reception here regarding burials and
funerals and then we've got kelly jarman
who works across the harbour waste and
grants maintenance support and staff
um
and dealing with service requests um and
the few complaints that we might get
hopefully less this year going forward
um
so if i just go through the list as
we've done before so machinery wise
everything um
we purchased all our equipment there was
some delays on some of the equipment but
that seems to be uh
a worldwide problem at the moment
sourcing machinery
and then there is an additional cost
um due to the price increases so the
only machine we've got not in service at
the moment it's new batwing
which is um
the big triple mower um that's delayed
until september so that was an eight
month delay but as bruce said before
we purchased some second-hand equipment
um from tivoli
um so that that will cover us
at a at a reasonable price
it was the only other issue that i've
had which i've had to change in
councillor homes who won't be very happy
with this is the fact that
i was unable to get batteries
or any suppliers were unable to get
batteries for a number of the electrical
equipment that we were supposed to cap
so i purchased a lot of smaller handheld
tools
lower streamers hedge trimmers pump
cutters
um
the the blowers are unavailable and big
companies like you know still and
husqvarna
you know worldwide companies
were not able to supply the batteries
anywhere
um
so the grass is still growing so about
to purchase um alternatives which are
petrol initially um we have some battery
um but we're going to progress that as
we go forward
um the depot i don't know if you've seen
victoria parker had a chance to walk
past but the the staff
for the first week when they joined on
the first which was a friday i've been
cleaning out from previous occupants
um tidying getting the green houses back
into shape
and making them more presentable which
they've done
and it is a lot better
um the cctv has been fitted with an
intruder alarm and security's been
increased obviously
um because we've typically had a number
of breakdown break-ins
with equipment stolen
um and the guys off their own back now
um
have
used the greenhouses and they're they're
planting well any off cuts and shoots
and saplings that they get they're
already planting um
in there and watering for future use
which is good
the software system i think john
mentioned last time we've got a bespoke
software system that's used by a number
of councils um
we have had a
so all the tasks are in on this system
for each crew through the staffing
is the fact that then when they're on
site they have their tasks and jobs to
do
um and then once they've completed it
they can upload any issues take
photographs to say it's been completed
that will come back um
to the office um and then with the
supervisor and mike it's in that area or
any other my supervisors they can check
agree tick off um so we ensure that the
standards high we have had one or two
problems as you would expect in the
rural areas where there's no signal it
doesn't seem to upload or accept photos
but we were working with the suppliers
to to hopefully
um improve that
the player inspections also go into the
system which the supervisor and one of
the other operatives who was qualified
to undertake
so
there is a a group of staff that can see
those including adrian avery and a
number of officers so it's all in one
place
before we've had like a number of
services in different areas with
different sections but everything is
contained with more pictures
item list and everything which will only
progress us with the play strategy and
and highlighting things going forward
trees
um we like i said john said last time
we're using uh the company that supplied
north devon those economies are scaled
there um we were fortunate that tivoli
did hand over all the information that
we required regarding clustering of
trees and recent schedules of six twelve
eighteen or two and a half years
whatever the group of trees need
so that's that's carrying on
um
and progressing which is good
so where we are today the first cut
of the season has been done in
torrington and wholesaling
as you know first cut is always the
heaviest
normally what would have happened is
tivoli would have cut in march to get
ahead just to get that ground
lifted
but they decided that that wasn't going
to happen
obviously because it's the end of the
contract
so they are behind
and the staff were told not to do it so
that we are
behind slightly in the fact that it is
taking over the first cut but once this
is out of the way
um
we will be moving forward on the correct
schedule
like i said when the team is at full
complement next
week we split them into grass cutting
more than two which is basically
uh bigger areas and pedestrian sweepers
sweepers there's a waste of recycling
that one very long before i brought that
one in and pedestrian rural cutting and
then we'll have the horticultural team
also including the cemeteries because
cemeteries take a lot longer because of
the design
this year
as we've discussed and as it's all been
agreed and it's been discussed a number
of times through climate change as well
is we're going to assess our estate
so that we know the schedules are right
the flexibility we've got with having
our staff in houses
we don't have to cut when it's raining
just so that we get that cut in so that
the invoice can be paid the torridge can
be charged
we can
schedule and rotate the system so that
you don't create more work by cutting so
if you're cutting the wet or you're
streaming the wet
everything's a mess basically the
gravestones everything curves and it
takes longer once it dries out so for us
it's about tailoring that schedule and
if the seasons as they're changing
extent we can extend our cutting you
know it's always been on a program of
the contract says this 20 cats 16 cuts
14 cups
well as the season's changed and have
changed it might not necessarily need
that in a certain time period and we now
have the flexibility and i have the
control to say no we're changing that
that this is the way we go
um
and this whole year
and and with councillor hamza is just
scope our state and include embedding
plants which we've discussed many times
going forward
how what plants we put in
um going forward
but first of all we need to assess on
the information we've got the
information we receive from tivoli is
you know the actual bed implants
number of those have been taken out over
the years
do they need to go back in do we need to
to create something different what are
the schemes what are the routes and
that's what we're working to at the
moment
um so yeah
i'm pleased how it started once we i'll
have a true understanding once we get
all the staff in
um
and then we know what can be achieved
um
to improve the service
but for for me it's more of a case
taking anything out of a contract
sometimes when safe multiple recycle
came in it's all about the standard and
the quality
not cut as much as you can as quickly as
you can
to move on to get the invoice in for
something else it's about that standard
so your edges of payments
you're blowing the curves off because if
you cut any piece of
land or ground that's in the public
domain and there's a path running
through the middle you can cut the grass
perfectly
but if the path has got grass all on the
edges that's all the members of the
public council is normally
so it's about that attention to detail
really and we've got a good number of
staff with a lot of experience so
that's where we are happy to take any
questions
that's good
right first thing
i'll go with
you first thank you thank you very much
for your report it
answers the questions
i'm an eastern water councillor so um
it's knee high in a minute yeah um
[Music]
thank you very much
uh regarding victorian park
and things like that but i appreciate
that you are
you know just getting the new staff in
yeah recent years
you know and this you know and they can
be military this service won't be wrong
excuses excuses excuses because that's
not how our services were but for us
it's a case of
because the cut wasn't done in march
which you normally would get ahead we
are behind
um for this first cut but
only by a week
so once that is done and then when it
brings you we will be on to the all the
bedding
um preparing the beds
um before the planting season so before
the plants come in
um which will be the middle that easter
water will be done this week they're
hoping to finish first cut this week
[Music]
to do with the battery shortage exactly
so universal shortage due to maybe
greater demand now for battery equipment
or is the surprise situation
and does it just
does it apply to a particular brand that
you're going with on a contract basis or
i'm just to say that at northern we have
demonstrations of equipment from um
people in south moulton the
and then just to comment about
you know it's
the cutting regime again
if you're going on a short term for
petrol powered equipment then that is an
opportunity
to
just cut margins in our parks and to
let's
the background grass has grown in common
with what other authorities are doing
you know we all know the arguments andy
bell came to the council recently and
told us about crisis in wildlife
leaving areas back from the margins to
grow
encourages wildlife
and it also reduces our cutting costs so
i was about richard i'll say that
possibly or looking at that in the next
year or two the future way it's um
you know you're going for petrol
equipment now because the battery is
saying uh to me that she hasn't
sort of looking at uh just marching
cutting on in our parks well
yes
so
first
battery wise um i think it's a lot to do
with supply
um on top of the two brands what we were
looking at for commercial you know this
this is commercial full day's work it's
still an artist cabana
worldwide companies big companies
um you know we can all go to amazon or
argos and pick up a battery streamer but
that isn't really sufficient for what we
need with eight hours work with battery
packs so it is a lot i think
no expert whether it's china or of
supply across
um
europe or worldwide but there is a
demand
and
the company that we were attended to
look at this you know they were scouring
the country to find these batteries
um
i had to source two from south mountain
from a supplier there
that
were at retail price
so it was extremely
expensive to get those batteries for
those two machines but we needed them
as we've discussed many many times
in the climate change and other meetings
and when you come and saw me uh in my
office is the fact that we are scooping
out this year our estate we are carrying
on where we are
as a
running the cleansing section as well as
you know if you leave the edges to
grow well in certain areas in urban
recreational areas
you'll have a
certain
number of people that will residents
that think that's the way to go for the
vast majority or a high number will say
that is not and that's where the dogs go
and that's where they
do their business that's where you'll
get your needles your glass and your
litter
so
we scope out this year and collectively
i'm working
a way forward for our estate as a whole
just to comment that other local
authorities managed to do this hopefully
as well
anybody else
oh sharon
okay
just a quick one are you getting a
positive reaction from the staff because
you're putting more emphasis on the
quality of work as opposed to racing
through to get the invoice you know what
i mean is there a positive reaction
because they're able to use their
expertise and everything better
obviously i can't discuss previously
what went on with the
previous employers but
um
and i'm bound to say that as their
manager
um
best positive right now and they feel
supported more
um because there is a presence
of support nearby
and the guys that have come on and it is
a bit of a culture change for them
working from any
contract to public authority it is about
that service standard
whereas before it was all about
achieving targets
um
and then any disputes were argued at
management meetings with the contract
client contractor meetings
which then snowballs and snuggles and
takes some time so now it is about the
quality over
um the quantity
but they do have a fair
fairly high
workload each day
this is new again just like what
happened when when you took over the
waste and recycling yeah you know
it was all
trying to sort out to start with but it
came good and i'm sure
with your expertise
okay we'll move on then thank you
richard thank you all
um
i think 12
consideration of the forward plan well
historically we do this
first
and
for the first meeting we've got you know
to go for the first meeting but i'm sure
we'll we'll have something on it by the
time it comes around
yeah of course we've got the qbr qbr4
yeah that's fine so that means we will
go through the
um
forward that we want to put on each one
i mean we've got we've got things we've
got things to fill out
um
[Music]
with you
1106.
and